do you guys ever wonder what would
happen if we just disappeared off the
face of the Earth
I mean I
species of one day we just didn't exist
anymore
what do you think would happen
a portion of this video is sponsored by
HP
so I used to live in Toronto and there
was a building that I used to spend a
lot of time in I used to study there I
did my research there and I did my
thesis there
but a lot of people
hated this building like they hated this
building with a passion
it was one of those buildings that
everyone had an opinion about because
when you walk by it it's impossible to
ignore it it's this massive block of
concrete and it has a very dominating
presence it has this attitude of I don't
give a crap what anyone thinks about me
which is kind of a bizarre idea
buildings are designed to impress people
and you know as Architects we go through
so many public consultations you know
sometimes it's a little bit of an
Overkill but you know people actually
have a say in what the building is
supposed to look like and they have a
say all the way down to the color of the
building I remember when I was working
at my very first job here in Vancouver
we had this white brick building in
Chinatown and the Chinatown Council said
no we don't want this white represents
death in Chinese culture and so they
wanted us to change the color of the
building
[Music]
so public opinion you know whether you
like it or not it does have an impact on
the building's design the building has
to kind of justify their presence in
some way they actually did talk about
removing this building a lot but
apparently it would take the force of an
atomic bomb to destroy this thing
and it would cost more and it would do
more environmental damage to demolish it
than to just renovate it
and so they ended up just slapping on a
glass facade and cover it up for my
energy consumption point of view this
building is just an energy consuming
monster it's poorly insulated it's
poorly waterproofed this thing is just
one big thermal bridge for those of you
who don't know how cold it gets in
Toronto it gets friggin cold it gets
down to negative 30 degrees it's brutal
it's also one of the reasons why I left
Toronto also from a carbon footprint
point of view concrete consumes so much
carbon when it's being built and this
building is just so wrong in so many
ways but there is a small group of
people who seem to really love this
building and just brutalist architecture
in general and I do think I get the
appeal
it's the lack of pretentiousness and
it's the integrity and it's the I don't
give a crap attitude because in the end
this building is going to be here long
after my
little existence
and it's gonna be here long after we're
gone we are actually the temporary
visitors to this building
[Music]
the thing that surprised me the most is
just the sheer speed in which nature
starts to take over apparently just in
the first couple of years native animal
species start to come back
foreign
[Music]
did you know that the Blue Heron is a
native species to Toronto I don't think
I've ever seen a blue heron in Toronto
before
[Music]
to film the drawing segment of this
video I used a 4K webcam because it
allows me to film very long sessions
without having to worry about storage
which is usually an issue when I'm
filming with my phone I use the HP 965
as a 4K input device in OBS and attach
it to this articulated arm with a
quarter inch screw hole this webcam
feels really solid and it's swivel
adjustable which allows me to frame my
shot exactly the way I want it the image
quality is really good and it captures
all of the details in my drawing once
everything's set up and I need to press
the record button all the footage is
going to be saved directly onto my
laptop this camera is also really great
for video calls since it has a built-in
AI face framing autofocus system and
audio noise reduction if you want to
learn more about this HP 965 webcam I'll
leave the link in the description
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
just a couple of years native plant
species start to come back and they
start to thrive you'll see moss and
trees and flowers crawling up buildings
[Music]
thank you
all the books especially in the rare
books library will get wet they would
start to grow mold and fungi and maybe
it could become a really rich habitat
for a lot of different animal species by
the way if you're interested in any of
my procreate assets I'll leave the link
in the description
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
since it connects all the floors and has
the most access to Daylight could become
a breeding ground for different plants
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
we see everything from a human-centric
point of view and how could we not
everything around us exists in relation
to us and fundamentally it's a tool to
serve us form follows function the human
function so buildings existence is
Justified as long as it serves us and as
long as we like it and maybe because we
relatively have pretty short lives we
think about the lifespan of buildings in
a very limited way too typical life
expectancy of a building is something
around 50 years and by that time the
buildings become so deteriorated or
outdated that you have to decide whether
you want to demolish it or you want to
renovate it it's so hard to even
conceptualize a world without us but in
the grand time span of the earth and
even in the grand scale of the Galaxy we
are to just a tiny tiny little blip if
it happens for some freak accident we
just get wiped off the face of the Earth
or maybe it happens in a couple
thousands of years maybe it's just the
natural decline of our species or we
just end up killing ourselves what would
happen to our buildings which of them
would become artifacts and what do they
become without us
[Music]
this is a new format that I'm
experimenting with again so if you liked
it if you like this conceptual sketching
type video or if you have any
suggestions on how to make it better let
me know in the comments and I have a
Discord server if you want to keep in
touch with the community I'll leave the
link in the description and with that
I'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]